¿Qué tal si la usamos? Combinamos eso con el número 3,
no usar tierra cultivable.
Porque esas tierras ya se están cultivando
y son escasas en el mundo.
Nº 2: No competir con cultivos alimentarios.
Eso está ya bien establecido. no se requiere nada más.
Por último, el recurso más precioso que tenemos en la Tierra
es el agua dulce; no usar agua dulce.
Si el 97.5% del agua en el mundo es salada,
2.5% es agua dulce. Menos de la mitad de esto
está disponible para uso humano.
El 60% de la población se abastece de ese 1%.
Para resolver mi problema, tenía que ser verde extremo
y cumplir con esas 3 grandes medidas.
Damas y caballeros: bienvenidos al laborartorio de investigación GreenLab.
Este es una entidad dedicada a la próxima generación
de combustibles de aviación que usan halófitas.
Una halófita es una planta que tolera la sal.
A la mayoría de las plantas no les gusta la sal, pero las halófitas la toleran.
También usamos malezas,
al igual que algas.
Lo bueno de nuestro laboratorio es que hemos
tenido 3600 visitantes en los últimos 2 años.
¿A qué se debe eso?
Es porque estamos haciendo algo especial.
En la parte baja ven al GreenLab, obviamente.
A la derecha ven las algas.
Estando involucrados en la próxima generación
de combustibles de aviación, las algas son una opción viable.
Hoy hay mucho financiamiento
y tenemos un programa de algas para combustibles.
Existen dos maneras de desarrollar algas.
Una es un fotobiorreactor cerrado que ven aquí.
Lo que aparece al otro lado es nuestra especie,
la que usamos en el momento que se llama Scenedesmus Diamorphis.
Nuestro trabajo en la NASA es tomar los datos experimentales y computacionales
para hacer la mejor mezcla para el fotobiorreactor cerrado.
El problema con estos fotobiorreactores es
que son bastante costosos, están automatizados,
lo que hace muy difícil producirlos a gran escala.
¿Qué se usa a gran escala?
Se usan sistemas de tanques abiertos.
En todas partes del mundo se están cultivando algas
con como circuitos, como ven aquí.
Como un óvalo con una rueda de paletas para mezclar bien
pero cuando llega a la última ronda, que yo llamo la cuarta, se estanca.
Tenemos solución para eso.
En el sistema de estanque abierto de GreenLab
usamos algo que ocurre en la naturaleza; las olas.
Con la tecnología de olas, en el sistema de tanques abiertos,
logramos mezclas del 95% y el contenido de lípidos es mayor
al del sistema del fotobiorreactor cerrado,
lo cual, pensamos, es significativo.
Pero las algas tienen una desventaja; son muy costosas.
¿Habrá alguna forma de producir algas económicamente?
La respuesta es, sí.
Hacemos lo mismo que con las halófitas,
es decir, adaptación climática.
En GreenLab tenemos seis ecosistemas primarios
que van alterándose desde agua dulce hasta llegar a la salada.
¿Qué hacemos?
Tomamos una especie potencial, empezamos con agua dulce,
le agregamos un poco de sal.
Éste, el segundo tanque aquí, equivale al ecosistema de Brasil.
Al lado de los campos de caña de azúcar se pueden tener nuestras plantas.
El siguiente tanque representa África, el siguiente Arizona,
el siguiente Florida, y el que sigue representa California o el mar abierto.
Lo que estamos intentando es conseguir una sola especie
que pueda sobrevivir en cualquier parte del mundo, aunque sea un desierto árido.
Hasta ahora hemos tenido mucho éxito.
Ahora, uno de nuestros problemas.
Para los agricultores hay 5 requisitos para tener éxito:
Se necesitan semillas, suelo, agua, sol
y, por último, fertilizantes.
La mayoría usa fertilizantes químicos. Pero ¿saben algo?
Nosotros no usamos fertilizantes químicos.
¡Un momento! Veo mucho verde en tu laboratorio. Seguro usan fertilizantes.
Aunque no lo crean, en los análisis de los ecosistemas de agua salada,
el 80% de lo que necesitamos está dentro de estos tanques.
El 20% faltante es nitrógeno y fósforo.
Nuestra solución natural es, peces.
No picamos los peces para echarlos ahí. (Risas)
Usamos los deshechos de los peces; es más
usamos peces poecilia de agua dulce con la técnica de adaptación climática
gradualmente desde agua dulce hasta agua salada.
Los poecilias de agua dulce son baratos, les encanta tener bebés
y les fascina ir al baño.
Cuanto más van al baño, más fertilizante obtenemos,
mejor para nosotros, aunque no lo crean.
Cabe notar que usamos arena como piso,
arena común de playa, o sea, crustáceos fosilizados.
Muchos me preguntan, ¿cómo empezaste?
Bueno, empezamos con lo que llamamos biocombustibles de laboratorio bajo techo.
Es un laboratorio semillero donde tenemos 26 especies diferentes de halófitas
y cinco son ganadoras. Lo que hacemos es...
debería llamarse laboratorio de la muerte, porque intentamos
matar semillas, hacerlas resistentes
y luego vamos al laboratorio verde.
Lo que ven en la esquina inferior
es una planta experimental de tratamiento de residuos
donde estamos desarrollando, una macroalga de la que hablaré en un minuto.
Y por último, ese soy yo en el laboratorio para mostrarles
que también trabajo; no solo hablo de lo que hago.
Aquí están las especies de plantas, Salicornia virginica.
Es una planta maravillosa, me encanta.
Se ve por todas partes, desde Maine,
por todas partes hasta California. La adoro.
La segunda es Salicornia Bigelovi, muy díficil de encontrar.
Es la que tiene más alto contenido de lípidos,
pero con una desventaja: es enana.
Y ahora, la Salicornia europaea, la más grande o más alta.
Lo que estamos intentando
con selección natural o biología adaptativa, es combinar las tres
y hacer una planta más alta con mucho lípido.
Cuando un huracán diezmó la Bahía de Delaware,
los campos de soya desaparecieron.
Se nos ocurrió una idea: ¿podremos tener una planta
con la que se pueda recuperar el suelo de Delaware? La respuesta es sí.
Y se llama malva de la costa, Kosteletzkya virginica,
repitan eso cinco veces, bien rápido, si pueden.
Es una planta 100% útil; las semillas como biocombustible y el resto para forraje.
Ha estado ahí por 10 años y funciona muy bien.
Ahora veamos la Chaetomorpha,
que es una macroalga a la que
le encantan los nutrientes en exceso.
saben que se usa para limpiar tanques sucios.
Esta especie es muy importante para nosotros.
Sus propiedades se acercan al plástico.
Intentamos ahora convertir estas macroalgas en bioplástico.
Si tenemos éxito, revolucionaremos la industria de los plásticos.
Tenemos ya una semilla para el programa de biocombustibles.
Tenemos que hacer algo con esta biomasa que resulta.
Hacemos extracción GC, optimización de lípido y demás,
porque nuestra meta es crear
la próxima generación de combustibles para aviación... y lo que sigue.
Hasta ahora hemos hablado de agua y combustibles,
pero en el camino nos encontramos con algo interesante sobre la Salicornia;
es un producto alimenticio.
Hablamos de ideas que vale la pena difundir ¿no?
Qué tal esta: en África subsahariana, próxima al mar,
agua salada, desierto árido... ¿qué tal si cultivamos esa planta;
la mitad como alimento y la mitad como combustible.
Podemos lograrlo sin grandes costos.
Hay un invernadero en Alemania
que lo vende como alimento saludable.
Se cultiva y aquí en el medio, hay camarones para encurtir.
Tengo que contarles un chiste. A la Salicornia se le conoce
como frijoles de mar, espárragos marinos y algas en escabeche.
Estamos encurtiendo algas en escabeche, en el medio.
Bueno, pensé que era divertido. (Risas)
Y abajo, mostaza náutica.
y tienes un gran platillo con galletas.
Y por último, ajo con Salicornia, que es lo que más me gusta.
O sea, agua, combustible y alimentos.
Nada de esto sería posible sin el equipo del GreenLab.
Así como Miami Heat tiene sus 3 grandes,
nosotros tenemos nuestros 3 grandes en GRC de la NASA:
Ahí estamos con el profesor Bob Herndricks, nuestro temerario líder,
y el doctor Arnon Chait.
La columna vertebral del GreenLab son los estudiantes.
En los últimos 2 años, hemos tenido 35 estudiantes
de todo el mundo, trabajando en el GreenLab.
A propósito, mi jefe de división repite: "tienes una universidad verde".
Y yo le digo: "Me parece bien porque estamos formando
la próxima generación de pensadores en verde extremo, lo que es importante".
Resumiendo, primero les presenté lo que pensamos
es una solución global para alimentos, combustibles y agua.
Algo falta para completarlo.
Obviamente usamos electricidad.
Les tengo una solución;; usamos fuentes de energía limpia.
Tenemos dos turbinas eólicas conectadas al GreenLab
y esperamos que pronto lleguen unas 4 o 5 más.
También estamos usando algo bastante interesante...
Hay un campo de paneles solares en el Centro de Investigación Glenn de la NASA,
sin uso desde hace 15 años.
Junto con algunos colegas, ingenieros eléctricos,
vimos que eran viable,
así que los estamos restaurando.
En unos 30 días los conectaremos al GreenLab.
Y la razón por la que ven rojo, rojo y amarillo, es que
mucha gente piensa que los empleados de la NASA no trabajan los sábados.
Esta es una foto tomada en sábado.
No hay autos pero vean mi camioneta amarilla. Yo sí trabajo los sábados. (Risas)
Así muestro que estoy trabajando.
Porque hacemos lo necesario para lograr el trabajo; todos lo saben.
Hay un concepto relacionado con esto:
Usamos el GreenLab como base de prueba
para la idea de una microred inteligente en Ohio.
Tenemos la capacidad de hacerlo y creo que funcionará.
Allá en el laboratorio de investigación de GreenLab.
Un ecosistema de energía renovable autosostenible,
es lo que he presentado hoy.
En verdad espero y deseo que este concepto
se extienda por todo el mundo.
Creemos tener una solución
para alimentos, agua, combustibles, y también energía. Todo completo
Es verde extremo, sostenible, alternativo y renovable,
y cumple con las tres grandes de GRC:
no usa tierras fértiles, no compite con cultivos alimenticios,
y sobre todo, no usa agua dulce.
Me preguntan mucho, "¿y tú qué haces en el laboratorio?"
Mi respuesta habitual es, "No te importa. Eso es lo que hago". (Risas)
Aunque no lo crean, mi primera meta de trabajo
en este proyecto es:
quiero ayudar a salvar el mundo.